i can change everything with one  decision this is one of my favorite  sayings you're only one decision away  from changing your life forever and  whenever i feel overwhelmed or i feel  like i'm decreasing like i feel  powerless i feel like i have less power  than i want to have i always say this to  myself because it's like i can take one  decision to change [ __ ] everything i  mean like i can drink a bottle of jack  get in the car i can change everything  with one decision i can make a step to  to invest in something i can buy  something i can invest in myself i can  have a terrible conversation with an  amazing conversation with layla but just  one decision and that's always given me  power but the thing is is that instead  of changing our lives we blame when i  say blame i want you to think give power  to sources outside of our control and  this is what you and this is what your  prospects and your customers are doing